[Musique]
les étudiants al'inverse leurs collègues
parisiens
aucun incident aujourd'hui à signaler à
lyon la journée a été calme comme le
montrent ces images prises aux abords
des facultés mais dans les amphis l'on a
discuté des récents événements l'unef et
nagel prépare pour demain une grève
générale de cours en liaison avec le
syndicat national de l'enseignement
supérieur
dans le même temps s'ouvrait à la
bibliothèque de la doua l'assemblée
générale à des universités francophones
qui se poursuivra jusqu'au 12 mai en
présence de messieurs louis elfassi
respectivement recteurs des universités
de lyon et rabat
[Musique]